Israel weil Herr Wolfson heute hier
ist die israelische oder die die
deutsche staatsreson Israel ist deutsche
staatsreson gilt das auch für Sie her
kopala ja D muss man erstmal definieren
was staatsesorung eigentlich heißt ja
das weiß ich eben nicht kann mir das
jemand erklären wurde das irgendwo mal
erklärt was das
heißt wenn sie uns regelmäßig gucken
dann ja ich guck sie nur nicht
regelmäßig aber das hat von der
deutschen staatsung hat Frau Merkel 2008
gesprochen ohne eine Debatte eine
Diskussion zu eröffnen was staatssaison
eigentlich bedeutet heißt das dass wir
Israel militärisch unterstützen dass die
Bundeswehr Israel militärisch
unterstützt wo steht das wo wurde das
ich frage Sie Herr nein ich weiß es
nicht deswegen frage ich jetzt mal
zurück und Herr Wolfson ist da der kann
uns vielleicht erklären Entschuldigung
sie sind der Chef einer Partei die
gerade in Ostdeutschland bei über 30%
steht ja und wir müssen sie doch wissen
was deutsche staatsres nein ich ich hör
diesen Begriff immer wieder aber mir
kann niemand genau erklären was es
eigentlich bedeutet Herr Wolfson können
sie helfen also ich kann hier in diesem
Falle die ehemalige Bundeskanzlerin
zitieren und es wundert mich dass sie
das nicht wissen ich weiß ich hab gesagt
dass sie 2008 hat sie diesen Begriff
geprägt ja ich weiß einfach so
wahrscheinlich nicht einfach so aber
ausen ja bitte aber okay also die
Bundeskanzlerin hat jenseits dieses
schönen Wortes das ehfurcht gebietend
ist kli und klar gesagt dass ein ich
zitiere fast wörtlich ein Angriff auf
Israel einem Angriff auf die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland gleich käbe
egal ob es Ihnen gefällt oder nicht das
war also eine klare Begriffsbestimmung
und diese Begriffsbestimmung halte ich
auch für höchst problematisch sie ist
zwar sehr sympathisch aber sie ist
deshalb problematisch ja weil Frau
Merkel ganz eindeutig ohne Konsultation
der natopartner hier Artikel 5 des
natotrages hat wirksam werden lassen
denn ein Angriff auf die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland Klammer auf wäre also auch
ein Angriff auf Israel würde den
Bündnisfall hervorrufen und das heißt
dass auch die Türkei beispielsweise ihr
neuer Freund Erdogan oder von ein KR ihr
Freund Freund ja es schätzt ihn sehr
ganz ein als Vorbild hat er ih
bezeichnet jedenfalls wäre dann für die
natoartner die Verpflichtung Israel zu
Hilfe zu kommen ob das richtig ist oder
falsch ist ist eine andere Sache
jedenfalls ist das klar definiert worden
und alles was ansonsten als ich muss das
schon sagen Blabla in Bezug auf
Staatsraison gebraucht wird ist
äm Interpretation sehr viel klarer ist
Robert habbeck in seiner videoansprache
gewesen der hat das ä mit Hand und Fuß
bedacht er hat das von sich aus klar
definiert höchst sympathisch definiert
nicht den Wolken kuukucksheim sondern
ganz konkret realistisch aber wenn wir
von der ehemaligen Bundeskanzlerin
sprechen wares ein Versprechen das im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes auf Sand
gebaut ist denn auch Frau Merkel muss
gewusst haben dass die Bundeswehr auch
2008 in einem desolaten Zustand gewesen
ist das zu den Fakt
die wen mit NATO sozusagen ExpertInnen
in dem Fall spricht Florence gaau z.B
ich habe mich wir haben das schon einmal
hier verhandelt und da sagte sie auf die
Frage ob das denn stimmt
da können man sich drüber streiten ob
das dann sofort den NATO Bündnisfall
auslösen würde da GT's möglicherweise
juristisch noch mal eine Ausnahme na
wenn die Bundesrepublik sagt wir sind
angegriffen dann gilt in diesem Falle
die deutsche Definition und das heiß
trage nur vor was sie sagt sie sagt
natoartner müsst uns helfen genau sie
sagt in der Verkürzung wäre das so nicht
der Fall aber das kann man
möglicherweise auch anders
interpretieren ich frage deswegen Herr
kopaller weil ähm es interessant war die
Reaktion aus aus ihrer Partei nach dem 7
Oktober sie haben sehr lange gebraucht
sie und auch ihre sehr gute Freundin
Frau Weidel um sich dazu zu verhalten
das ist mir aufgefallen und Björn höcke
sagt bis heute dazu gar nichts warum
nicht die Frage ist jetzt warum BN höcke
dazu nichts sagt war hö nichts dazu sagt
reden Sie mit ihm darüber scheint ja ein
ein taktisches Kalkül zu sein das ist
kein taktisches kakü ich halte es ich
denke auch in solchen Situationen
erstmal verratsam nicht gleich aus sich
heraus zu sprudeln und erstmal als
verantwortungsvoller Politiker wie wir
sind äh auch erstmal die Lage zu checken
und auch erstmal sehen was passiert der
7 Oktober ist ja schon ein bisschen her
jetzt haben wir mittlerweile Dezember
moment mal also ist ja nicht so als wenn
wir uns bis heute nicht oder ich mich
dazu nicht geäußert hätte sie ja BN
höcke nicht ja noch mal börn höcke da
müssten sie BN höcke fragen sie können
mich ja jetzt nicht einzelnen Politiker
abfragen und warum die nichts gesagt
haben das kann ich ih nicht wollen nur
mal heute verstehen wo sie auch
kulturell stehen wo sie
sicherheitspolitch kulturell zu tun
Sicherheit poliitisch stehen wo sie
arbeitspolitisch stehen und und so
weiter die großen Themen sie selber
haben sich dann geäußert und sagten der
Angriff der Hamas auf Israel ist zu
verurteilen ich trauere um alle
Kriegstoten jetzt müssen die Staaten auf
dieeskalation setzen um einen
Flächenbrand abzuwenden diplomatie ist
das Gebot der
Stunde wie klingt das für Sie Herr
Wolfson ich stolper vor allem über den
Begriff Kriegstote ja also das ist das
erste aber das
erschütternde muss ich sagen dass ähm
die Inkompetenz ihrer Analyse die keine
Analyse ist äh mich hier schockiert und
wenn ich interessiert zugehört habe wie
bisher stelle ich fest sie flüchten sich
in Floskeln hinein sie sagen
Ursachenbekämpfung ohne dass sie genaue
Punkte benennen und jetzt eine Sekunde
jetzt bleiben wir mal bei dem Thema hier
äh sie sprechen von einem Angriff
zwischen einem allgemeinen Angriff und
einem terrorüberfall der einem Blut und
mordorgie gewesen ist gibt's einen
Unterschied ähm Angriff setzt im Grunde
genommen das Vokabular eines staatlichen
Akteurs voraus das heißt also auch ihr
Vokabular zeigt eine inhaltliche
Unsicherheit und wenn ich mir jetzt
überlege als deutscher Staatsbürger
unabhängig mal von meiner
Familiengeschichte möchte ich jemandem
der so inkompetent in der Wahl der
Begriffe ist und damit auch die
inhaltliche Unsicherheit zeigt mein
Gemeinwesen übertragen kann ich nur
sagen nein danke also dieser Angriff
dann
Kriegstote das war ein terroristischer
Überfall und warum benennen sie das
nicht so das ist eine verharmlosende
Sprache unabhängig davon ob sie
proisraelisch oder proalästinensisch
sind das ist keine Wiedergabe der
Wirklichkeit dann reden sie davon dass
die Staaten der Region auf die
Eskalation setzen müssen wer hat denn
die Eskalation begonnen keiner östlicher
Staat sondern eine terroristische
Vereinigung die über ein Territorium
herrscht und ein in einem Bürgerkrieg
die Macht einseitig ergriffen hat das
heißt ihr Vokabular zeigt dass sie die
Wirklichkeit intellektuell nicht
erfassen und wenn sie das nicht können
dann verhüte Gott dass sie politische
Verantwortung bekommen nicht nur in
Bezug auf den Nahen Osten sondern auf
dieses Deutschland überhaupt also Herr W
ich muss ihn ja sagen also dass es ein
Krieg ist hat Netanyahu relativ zeitig
als Präsident selbst betitelt einen Tag
danach Kriegstoten noch und damit damit
sind alle getöteten auch Kriegstote wenn
es ein Krieg ist den Herr Netanyahu
definiert hat nicht Tino kopala und in
twet jetzt auseinander zu fiselieren und
zu gucken wie man eventuell was meint
und was sie mir jetzt unterstellen
wollen natürlich war das ein
barbarischer Angriff aber muss man in
der Tonalität als Politiker sofort
das schärfste Schwert rausholen es ist
kein Krieg es ist natürlich ein Krieg
natürlich da haben sie
recht aber das war sie haben hier die
Bezug den Bezug genommen auf das was sie
Angriff nennen es war eine Blut und
Mord aber sie haben und sie sie bringen
beide Akteure in eine
gleichgewichtigkeit und sie versuchen
sich durch Floskeln jetzt wieder heraus
zuetten sie haben hier eine normative
gleichgewichtigkeit der Akteure und das
haben sie durch ihre quasi oder
scheinanalyse nicht äh widerlegen können
das ist ein Problem bei Ihnen und diese
wischiwchi äh Verharmlosung
ähm die ist ein allgemeines Thema auch
sie haben durchaus in dem einen Punkt
Recht der Zuwanderung natürlich die
europäische Zuwanderung ist eine andere
Zuwanderung als die Zuwanderung die wir
aus welchen Gründen auch immer mit
Defiziten die sie teilweise auch benannt
haben äh noch nicht integrieren konnten
aber sie stütten das Kind mit dem Bade
aus immer diese gleichgewichtigkeit und
da müssen sie ich muss das so ganz
oberlehrerhaft sagen wirklich die
Materie besser
durchdringen 219 kupaler Bewerbungsrede
für den Parteivorsitz da ging es auch
genau darum da ging es um ihre Haltung
auch zu Israel
und ich will auch noch mal deutlich
sagen geht jetzt nicht hier um und
Wortklauberei sondern es geht hier
tatsächlich um etwas sehr prinzipielles
und wir hören mal kurz rein was dort
passiert
ist warum haben sie bei dem eigenen AFD
Antrag sich der Stimme enthalten zur
Sicherung Israels ich habe mir diese
diesen BDS Antrag den sie jetzt meinen
genau angeguckt ich habe mich dort
enthalten übrigens hat die kompletten
anderen Parteien haben dagegen gestimmt
das will ich als erstes mal sagen ich
habe mich deswegen enthalten weil genau
diese Besetzung der palästinischen
palästinensischen Gebieter laut UN
völkerrechtswidrig sind und deswegen
konnte ich mich nicht entscheiden Pro
oder Kontra zu stimmen aber ich will es
ganz klar sagen ich stelle hier nicht
das Existenzrecht Israel in Frage ganz
eindeutig
nicht einmal erklären Herr wolfon können
Sie einm BDS erklären ja aber BDS ist
eine Bewegung die von Palästinensern
gegründet worden ist und viele
internationale Anhänger hat auch in
Deutschland Akademikern ja und die
fordert bds den boikott
disinvestition also Abzug von
Investition und Sanktionen gegen Israel
das ist das rein faktische Israel
boyottieren auf allen möglichen Ebenen
kulturell wirtschaftlich Polit genau was
eine große Dummheit ist denn der Israel
ist eine sehr fortschrittliche Nation
nicht zuletzt im Bereich der
Wissenschaft und
man sägt nicht den Ast ab auf dem man
selber sitzt die internationale
Wissenschaftsszene die wirtschaftsszene
profitiert von israelischenem knowau
ganz dramatisch also nicht zuletzt in
Bezug auf IT Technologie ist fast jedes
bedeutende deutsche Unternehmen in
irgendeiner Feise Weise mit Israel
verbunden aus selbstwck nicht aus Liebe
nicht aus Vergangenheitsbewältigung
sondern a reinen geschäftlichen und
überzeugenden Sinne und jetzt wieder mal
die mangelnde Fachlichkeit der kupala
sie reden im Jahre 2019 von israelischer
Besatzung der Gazastreifen ist seit 2005
nicht Israel besetzt also wenn die
solche allgemeinen
floss aber sie reden von besetzten
Gebieten und gaserstreifen ist
freiwillig in 2005 von Israel geräumt
worden also alles diese
pauschalitäten ein bisschen stimmt ein
bisschen stimmt es nicht und dann sind
alle Leute begeistert oder verärgert
aber sie zeigen immer wieder eine
mangelnde Professionalität in jedem
Bereich und das finde ich betigend ich
rede gar nicht jetzt mal über dieide
Position sondern die fachlichen
Positionen die Unbeholfenheit der
Analyse die Unbeholfenheit der Sprache
sie können es nicht meinen sie das ja
Herr W das entscheiden aber immer noch
die
Wähler selverständlich aber man muss
deswegen die Wähler aufklären und sagen
liebe Wähler euch liegt doch an der
Prosperität am Wohlstand an der
Bewahrung des Wohlstandes der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland wollt ihr
euch den Ast absehen auf dem ihr sitzt
ja oder nein gut dann fragen sie w W
vernichtet den aktuell Wohlstand in
diesem Land ist das die AFD oder die
aktuelle Bundesregierung das
ist kann man al natürlich immer von der
Opposition aus immer leichter sagen und
sie werden doch aber nicht bestreiten
dass es hier einen guten Willen gibt
dass es hier auch sehr fähige Politiker
gibt dass es fähige Berater gibt und
sind nicht alles nur Idioten wenn ich
mir jetzt auf der anderen Seite
diejenigen in der AFD schaue die die
Kritik aus die Kritik üben und mich
frage wirken die kompetenter in ihrer
Argumentation da kann ich sagen nein
noch weniger das heißt das was ich bei
Ihnen ganz persönlich aufgrund dieser
Beispiele bemängle bemängle ich auch bei
vielen anderen ihrer Kollegen ich bin da
ganz nüchtern das heißt die
Professionalität zeht ich will einmal um
das ganze Bild zu zeichnen Wolfson wir
haben uns beim letzten mal auch glaube
ich kurz darüber
unterhalten ich habe sie gefragt nach
dem
Westjordanland Westbank und sie sagten
klar besetzte Gebiete Gaza andere
Situation will aber trotzdem daruf
hinweisen es gibt zwei Resolutionen der
UN wegen Gaza
äh und zwar deswegen weil man sagt ähm
da gibt es nicht die Bewegungsfreiheit
und da gibt es auch die Lufthoheit die
von Israel kontrolliert wird so habe ich
das zumindest irgendwo tief im am
Hinterkopf sitzen deswegen gibt es diese
beiden Resolutionen das heißt wenn Herr
kopalla sagt da gibt es Resolutionen
hatte damit nicht Unrecht das ist
richtig aber da muss man natürlich ja
richtig aber da muss man fragen wie
kommen diese Resolution zustande sind
die Resolutionen die
Institutionalisierung a der Moral B
treffen die Fakten zu und jetzt komme
ich also hier darauf diese Dinge die sie
hier beschrieben haben und die in der
unoesolution den unoresolutionen benannt
werden benennen nicht die Ursache denn
die Ursache sind die ständigen
beschießungen israelischen Gebietes
durch Raketen es war der Rückzug im
Jahre 2005 geplant um ein Hongkong oder
Singapur im Nahen Osten zu ermöglichen
mit Freihandelszone was sie für die
neuen Bundesländer wollten haben die
Israelis dem allen
zugestimmt wie auch immer können sie
nennen das B wie sie wollen mit anderen
Worten das heißt hier hat die
palästinensische hamasführung ihre
eigene Bevölkerung in diese Situation
gebracht die im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes höllisch ist wer ist dafür
verantwortlich diejenigen die das
verursacht haben und da ist die UNO
deren Zusammensetzung wir kennen
wahrlich alles andere als die
Institutionalisierung von ich will es
nur sagen wenn wir versuchen sozusagen
das ganze Bild zu zeichnen dann müssen
wir auch das dazu sagen ganz
grundsätzlich ihr Bild von Amerika K was
haben sie für ein Bild von
Amerika ist wem stehen sie n Amerika
oder
Russland ich stell ich stehe Deutschland
aber das ist nicht die Antwort auf die
Frage wem stehen sie näher wenn Sie wenn
Sie jetzt sich anschicken eine
politische Kraft zu werden eine Ernst
zuende müssen Sie diese Frage
beantworten die kann ich ih beantworten
also wer ist unserer besserer Partner
ist es Russland oder ist es sind beides
verlässliche Partner gewesen in der
Vergangenheit und das sollten Sie in
Zukunft auch wieder werden und für mich
gerade als Europäer da bin ich wieder
bei dem Punkt zählt Russland zu Europa
und es wird auch ein Russland nach
Vladimir Putin geben und auch Russland
wird nicht von der Landkarte
verschwinden und Amerika Amerika ist
genauso ein verlässlicher Partner und
ich war in Amerika schon gewesen und ich
finde das Land interessant auch
vielfältigistischen touristischen
natürlich auch ein als Land interessant
damit kommen wir jetzt hier nicht weiter
sie müssen mich ausreden lassen Herr LZ
und natürlich auch sie müssen mich
ausreden lassen und absolut natürlich
auch ein wichtiger Wirtschafts und
Handelspartner keine Frage von dem wir
auch profitieren und ein guter
Absatzmarkt für
uns ich habe kein aber gesagt ich aber
eins nee da haben sie sich
verhört das heißt was ist Russland dann
ist das gleichwertig ist das das gleiche
das Russland von Vladimir Putin ist das
gleich das ist gleichwertig für Sie das
sind zwei Weltmächte und ich denke wir
sollten mit beiden Weltmächten gute
wirtschaftliche und auch
partnerschaftliche Beziehung auf die
gleiche Art und Weise absolut das muss
das Ziel Deutschlands sein Zitat von
ihnen ich fordere Respekt für die
Ukraine ebenso wie für Russland dass wir
nicht mehr günstiges Gas aus Russland
importieren ist eben keine Reaktion auf
den ukrainekrieg robert habck hat den
Krieg zum Anlass genommen um die Importe
zu stoppen
korrekt aber er hat dieses Ziel schon
2016 verkündet Zitat weil wir ein
energiewendeland sind und ohne den Krieg
hätten die Bürger aber nicht hingenommen
dass wir diese Lebensader Ader unserer
Industrie durchtrennen das wusste er
jetzt liegt nordstream gesprengt von den
USA und Norwegen oder von der Ukraine
weiß man auch nicht so genau auf dem
Meeresboden und wir importieren
dreckiges freacking Gas aus Amerika
korrekt woher wissen sie das was weiß
ich dass das die Amerikaner die Norweger
oder vielleicht auch die Ukrainer
gesprengt haben ne wir wissen
zumindestens eins dass die Russen nicht
waren wissen wir das das wurde auch
natürlich von von sehr verläslichen
Quellen mittlerweile bestätigt dass die
Russen dass es die Russen nicht waren
und es
gibt die habe ich jetzt hier nicht parat
aber definitiv wurde immer davus ist ja
nicht trivial das muss man noch wissen
wen man das hat wei noch woher man hat
trivial finde ich dass man immer noch
nicht die Aufklärung vorangetrieben hat
wer es war und ich bin gespannt wenn es
ein sogenannte freundesstaat war okay
dann frage ich anders welche Quelle sagt
den dass es die USA oder Norwegen waren
ja es gab ja einen amerikanischen
Journalisten der das
sehr wohl äh auch in seiner Recherche
ermittelt hat und ich denke dass die die
auch die Aussagen die dazu geführt haben
wer diese Sprengung durchgeführt hat
dass es nur ein Staat sein kann diese
Sprengung überhaupt durchzuführen dass
es in diese Richtung gehen wird wer hat
den wer hat denn ein Interesse daran
Frage
musellen eine Interesse eine Interesse
Politik geht doch immer darum wie
gestaltet man das Leben wie gestaltet
man eine Gesellschaft und wenn sie wie
eben geschehen wie eben geschehen
unabhängig davon W das gesprengt
hat draußen unterwegs war sehr viel in
Archiven und ist jemand der und das sage
nicht ich sondern Leute auch von der New
York Times und andere sagen der ist in
den letzten Jahren seltsam abgebogen
zwar ist ein sehr verdienstvoller
Kollege aber muss aber nicht
unabhängig davon unabhängig geht Person
es geht darum wie wollen wir leben in
was für einem System und sie schildern
hier Russland praktisch gleichgewichtig
moralisch mit den Vereinigten Staaten
von Amerika das ist eine Feststellung
die sollen wir hier behalten und das
sollen auch die Wähler registrieren ich
kann dazu nur sagen wenn ich zu wählen
habe weiß ich ganz genau dass ich lieber
in den Vereinigten Staaten deutlich
lieber in den Vereinigten Staaten lebe
als in Putins Russland weil nach dem
Verhältnis von Russland zu Russland
gefragt worden ist ich verehre die
russische Literatur ich finde sie in
weiten Teilen besser wenn man das so
pauschal sagen darf als die
amerikanische aber deswegen bin ich noch
lange nicht dazu bereit das heutige
Russland gleichgewichtig mit den USA zu
nein das sie zeigen ihre
Wertigkeit und die ihre Wertigkeit geht
jetzt in Bezug auf den Iran da haben sie
ja auch das gleiche Argument im Grunde
genommen wir brauchen hier das iranische
Erdöl wir brauchen das iranische Erdgas
also verhandle ich mit denen ganz normal
als ob
das zuverlässiger Partner sag sie dar
ich ja aber jahrelang aber irgendwann
ist dann auch die Frage nach der a
Zuverlässigkeit zu stellen und die
Zuverlässigkeit hat auch was mit Ethik
zu tun nämlich Zuverlässigkeit heißt ich
kann mich auf den Partner verlassen
können Sie sich auf den Terrorstaat Iran
wirklich habe ich doch gar nicht
gesagtchuldigung entschuldigung aber
wenn sie ganz ganz kurz wenn sie von
Moral sprechen wissen Sie wenn wir von
Ländern die Angriffskriege geführt haben
keine wirtschaftlichen Beziehungen mehr
führen dürfen dann dürften wir auch kein
Öl und Gas von den USA kau flien wieder
ins allgemeine wir haben über den
gesprochen nein wir haben ganz Konk ich
möchte mit allen und wir möchten mit
allen ländn dieser Welt gute
wirtschaftliche Beziehung führen wir
möchten niemand ausschließen weil das
Herr Wolfs verher Konflikte und Kriege
und am Ende Menschenleben sehr
interessant sehr interessant das heißt
also für sie sind gleichgewichtige
Partner Diktaturen und Demokratie das
halte ich fest aus unserer unser
Gespräch doch wir können das nämlich
sehr wohl wir müssen nämlich wenn wir
gerade Partnerschaftlichkeit wollen und
im ökonomischen Sinne ich muss mich auf
einen Geschäftspartner verlassen können
ich muss mich auf den verlassen können
dass er zuverlässig liefert das hat
Russland immer getan ja aber in dem
Augenblick wo es ihm nicht mehr passt
dann eben nicht und die ST warum hat
getan und die strafm warum hat das getan
ja weil da natürlich eine
sanktionsspirale in Gang gegangen ist
und dann hat natürlich auch Russland
reagiert das ist doch Herr Wolfson das
ist doch wie überall es ist doch ein
Pendel ja richtig und wenn man zuschläg
kommt auch das Pendel wieder zurück und
das war im Prinip dann warum wir diese
Sanktion Anlassen haben und haben die
Sanktion was genutzt das ist wi and se
sie aber das doch die Ursachenforschung
das ist aber
Grunde
Entschuldigung die Reihenfolge ist jetzt
schon nicht unwesentlich ne erst Krieg
Angriff dann Sanktionen ja und haben wir
Sanktion gegen Amerika erlassen als sie
Irak Libyen platt gemacht haben aber
auch da wo ist da die Moral immer wieder
das gleich wo ist da die
Moral das war eine echte Tragödie weil
nämlich nicht nur die Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika auch der
Bundesnachrichtendienst auch die
russischen Geheimdienste alle
Geheimdienste dieser Welt von der
Annahme aus gegangen sind dass der Irak
Nuklearwaffen noch besitzt biologische
und chemische Waffen sowieso das war ein
Fehler aber ein
fehlerog im UN Sicherheitsrat das ist
immer BA das stimmt nicht Entschuldigung
der UN Sicherheitsrat nein also die
eindeutigen Informationen waren und da
hat also Cholin Paul auch ein bisschen
sich selbst überzuckert kurz um es war
ein
tragisches eine tragische Entscheidung
basierend auf falschen Informationen
also kurz um wieder vergleichen Sie
Äpfel mit Birnen sie vergleichen einen
demokratischen Staat wie die Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika mit Russland wir
wollen ja ein bisschen auch verstehen
was das bedeuten würde Gedankenspiel
internationale Beziehungen ein anderes
Land ist gerade gefallen als Stichwort
Iran wie sehen sie den Iran ich denke
dass Iran gerade im Nahen Osten ein ein
großer Player ist es ist fünfm so groß
wie Deutschland ist das ist das ein
Schurkenstaat was was bringt mir jetzt
diese Einstufung als schulkenstaat wir
müssen also ist es nicht wichtig wenn
man wenn man Außenpolitik wenn man
Wirtschaftspolitik W anderen politischen
Ordnung als unser als unsere westliche
Welt gibt ja gar keine Frage zwichen US
und Iran gibt es für Sie natürlich ist
es eine eine ein diktatorisch
aufgestellter Staat da gibt do keinen
Zweifel aber nicht nur das sondern das
wollen Sie als Partner jetzt gucken Sie
sich doch mal die Landkarte im Nahen
Osten an der Iran hat mit seinem woll
sie woll Iran angreifen der Iran hat hat
praktisch alle gemäßigten Staaten nicht
nur Israel sondern auch Saudi-Arabien
und andere arabische Staaten umzingelt
indem er praktisch Marionetten hat im
Libanon in Syrien im Irak die
innenpolitische Situation in
Saudi-Arabien unterminiert in bachrein
unterminiert und den die hutis im Jemen
mit anderen Worten das ist eine
Regionalmacht die den regionalen Frieden
und damit auch den Welthandel gefähr
nicht zuletzt in den letzten Tagen ist
die Piraterie der htis die von dem Iran
unterstützt werden eine
weltwirtschaftliche Herausforderung und
da reden sie als ob das ein ganz
normaler Staat ist doch das kommt doch
aus dem was sie
sagen mit diesen stat auch mit diesen
Staat haben wir diplomatische Beziehung
wir haben Botschaften und auch mit
diesen Staaten und auch mit diesen
Regierung ob uns das passt oder nicht
sollten wir gute Kontakte pflegen und
auch reden diplomatie ist da angesagt
wir können natürlich als schenstat
abstempel deklarieren wir wir wir hauen
die Botschaft da aus Deutschland heraus
und reden mit diesen Ländern nicht was
bringt uns das nicht reden davon das
sagt keiner sondern nur die Benennung
sinden sie mal jemand wird Sie
überraschen wenn ich das
sage die undifferenziert hat mit der Sie
hier kommen ganz anders Joschka Fischer
dessen Bewunderer ich nie gewesen bin
aber in dem Augenblick wo er im Iran war
hat er niemals seine Position
verheimlicht hat gesagt wir sind mit
eurer Politik einverstanden mit eurem
Wertesystem nicht und ihr werdet uns in
Bezug auf unsere Freundschaft mit Israel
nicht von diesem Kurs abbringen können
und sie kommen mit
allgemeinen an dieser Aussage von
Fischer gibt doch überhaupt nichts
abzustreiten wunderbar das heiß sind
Grünen
sind eine Aussage von J Fischer macht
lange noch nicht den Winter zum Sommer
also das muss zu verstehen also Satz aus
von jemandem aus ihrer Partei die
USA Arabien und Israel Stellen in
vielfacher Hinsicht eine Gefahr für den
Frieden im Nahen Osten da die USA wer
denn wer sagt das Israel
rogerbeckam das weiß ich
nicht so hat er nicht recht ich weiß
aber auch nicht ein bichchen
Zusammenhang er es erwähnt hat eine
Politik die die Autonomie Deutschlands
erhalten und stärken will sollte mit dem
Iran möglichst freundschaftliche
Beziehungen pflegen und weiterentwickeln
ist das auch von ihm Eugen Schmidt und
Roger beckamp ich denke gute
wirtschaftliche Beziehung sollten wir
auch zu zum Iran pflegen derselbe Roger
beckamp redet auch glaube ich vom
Erwachen des Irans weiß ich nicht was er
damit meint kann ich nicht sagen und sie
diskutieren in ihrer Partei darüber dass
man auch den Begriff Muller Regime bitte
nicht mehr verwenden sollte ja wissen
sie das ist das gleiche wie ich
erst ja ich denke mal auf
internationalen Pakett wird man auch
nicht von Mola Regime sprechen
so denke ich schon ich denke nicht dass
äh die Außenministerin wenn sie im Iran
sein sollte vom Mull Regime dur aber wir
sprechen hier und in auch auf AFD
Parteitagen spricht ja kann man ja
machen das noch mal es hat doch jeder
seine persönliche Meinung es gibt doch
keine es gibt doch keine keine keine
kein gleichlang nein die Meinung dürfen
sie haben wir finden die Meinung
interessant wir finden die Meinung
interessant wir haben die registriert
also ich ihre
Meinung verehen wür ich finde diese
Begrifflichkeit merreime in
keinsterweise förderlich was bringt die
uns weiter oh ja sagt uns sehr viel dass
das nämlich eine Theokratie ist in der
es eben die Freiheit des Individuums in
dem Sinne wie wir sie verstehen nicht
gibt also das ist wie gesagt
grundgesetzlich gesch ihre Meinung ist
grundgeszlich Meinung ist
grundgesetzlich geschützt aber wir
wissen jetzt dass
diejenigen
ver finde z.B auch solche Aussagen von
Herrn Kiesewetter sehr schwierig der
davon fabuliert hat dass z.B die
Sicherheit Israels wir mit unserem Leben
schützen müssten ja das ist die
for das ist die Fortsetzung von
Frau sypisch aber unrealistisch noch mal
ein anderer Begriff ganz zum Schluss ihr
Europa Kandidat Maximilian KR ja Europas
Eliten haben sich dem Globalismus
verschrieben und agieren als vasal der
USA hat er recht ich denke in vielen
Punkten was Globalismus angeht hat er
recht sie benutzen das Wort auch
Globalismus das benutzen sie ich benutze
es ab und an ich denke ich sehe das
aktuell gerade in der in in der
Neuordnung der Welt und das passiert ja
dass wir von der unipolarität in eine
Multipolarität kommen dass ich die größ
möchte das kleinere Mächte sich zusammen
schließen z.B die brickstaaten dass wir
in eine neue Weltordnung natürlich
kommen und dass dass der aktuelle Weg
die dieses Globalismus der Falsche ist
ist interessant sie wissen wer das Wort
als erster so richtig salonfähig gemacht
hat Globalismus nein Donald Trump ja hat
er unrcht also das heißt sie sie sehen
das auch so ich sehe es auch so und
Europa ist ein vasal der USA noch mal
gerade in der multipolaren Welt Russland
Amerika China als großer Player sollte
auch Europa die ganz andere Europa hat
andere Interessen als Amerika Europa hat
andere Interessen als china muss es sein
eigenen Weg finden das woll Europa
Schwächen das fordert übrigen auch
Emmanuel macron weil wir e andere
Interessen haben und Europa muss ich
natürlich dann ein Stück weit auch von
der wasalenschaft von
deralenschaft muss ich auch ein Stück
wasalenschaft Amerikas lösen alsoal und
einer Schutzmacht und Amerika schützt
uns und die den Beschützer von uns ob
wir uns stärker selbstverteidigen wollen
und können ist eine andere Frage aber
diejenige macht die unsere Freiheit seit
Jahrzehnten schützt ist für sie einal
finde ich auch interessant und den nleen
Schutzschirm
die USA auch über Europa ausbreiten
würden Sie denn dann gerne ersetzen nun
sie kennen unser Parteiprogramm W h klar
definiert Abzug amerikanischer Truppen
und auch Abzug der amerikanischen
Atomwaffen das heißt deutschland muss
sich vor allen Gefahren selber schützen
in Zukunft wenn die AFD regiert wir
haben immer gesagt dass wir natürlich
eine Bundeswehr brauchen die
verteidigungsfähig ist